6 25 on your friday morning we're
talking about the long-term future of
the 95 and the northern 215 beltway and
how it may include a big connection you
got it we're
centennial bowling
so somewhere down the road probably
after the centennial project is
scheduled to finish in 2024 it's likely
that us-95 in the northwest valley will
also be known as
i-11 so in the multi-layered world of
getting a project like this finalized
one of the things that has to happen is
something you may have heard of an
environmental impact statement except a
new facebook post from the nevada
department of transportation is a pretty
big mouthful basically saying it may not
take as long to complete let's check it
out um the i-11 environmental impact
statement is now a p-e-l a planning and
environmental linkages study okay
well the post goes on to explain that
back in january ndot in the federal
highway administration figured out that
a focused p e l study is going to
achieve the same objectives within a
shorter time period than a tier one eis
i hope i haven't lost you because ndot
does want to hear what you think about
where i11 is going to go through the
valley got an online public information
meeting opens on tuesday several
in-person meetings are scheduled to
we've got those links and links to this
and all of our centennial bolding
stories on eightnewsnow.com click
traffic then driving you crazy buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
bone if there is something driving you
crazy email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com